[Music]
hi my name is Alec Channel I'm the user
experience lead for foldable devices on
the Android platform team and in this
session we'll be talking about how to
build apps for foldables multi display
and large screen devices now we'll start
by looking at the range of devices which
are going to benefit from this session
then we will take a look at some of the
user experience considerations that you
should keep in mind as you are designing
your apps then we will dive a little bit
deeper into app continuity multi window
and multi display we are also delighted
to hear from our partners from Gameloft
and 1password and finally we'll finish
it off by looking at how you can test
your apps before you even get your hands
on these foldable devices so let's get
started when we talk about foldable
devices we are specifically looking at
the devices which have a display which
can fold now they come in two broad
categories number one is when you fold
the device the flexible display is on
the inside an example of that is the
Samsung Galaxy fold now typically these
devices will also have an additional
screen on the outside so that even when
the phone is folded you can use it as a
one-handed configuration maybe for doing
some quick actions the other category is
when you fold the display it fold the
phone that displays on the outside this
is the fold out configuration such as
huawei mate X now when these devices are
folded some part of the display is still
available like you know to use as a
regular phone in a100 configuration now
I'm sure you have
that Android is supporting foldables but
what this really mean for you what this
means is that if you follow some of the
best practices such as resize ability
handling configuration changes and using
saved instant state your app should just
work out of the box on these completely
new and innovative form factors that's
really the power of when a platform is
supporting these new devices now Android
supports innovation but you are the
innovators and we are so excited to see
the kind of experiences that you are
going to create on these new devices now
another interesting thing that you need
to keep in mind is that once you
optimize your applications to run well
on these sort of large unfolded displays
they will also work equally well on
hundreds of millions of Android tablets
which are already out there as well as
the Chrome OS devices which are capable
of running Android apps now let's take a
look at the UX considerations that you
should pay attention to when building
your apps for these devices immersive
experiences once you unfold these
devices whether they are like seven inch
or 8 inch display they're like just
absolutely gorgeous and you want to make
sure that you are really taking
advantage of every single pixel that is
available to you so these are really
good for things like gaming for watching
videos both consuming and more
importantly creating content for social
media as well as they're just absolutely
amazing for productivity so really make
sure that you are like embracing these
large fullscreen experiences next once
these devices are folded because that's
where like you know the magic happens
you can fold it and keep it in your
pocket you still want to make sure that
you are taking advantage of the fact
that these devices can be used
in a one-handed operation also so
depending upon the size of the screen
that is available to the user once the
phone is folded it may be just for
taking quick action it may also be just
used as a regular phone so make sure
that your apps are respecting both of
these configurations finally
multitasking this is one of those fields
which is gaining more importance with
these devices a lot of times you will
see that these devices are coming out
with nearly square form factor or very
close to it
what that means is that you can run to
18 by 9 windows next to each other side
by side so when you are multitasking
you're multitasking between almost 2
full displays next to each other so make
sure that you are taking advantage of
these new opportunities now speaking
about new aspect ratios this is
something that we definitely encourage
you to pay attention to you are probably
already very familiar with aspect ratios
like 16 by 9 or 18 by 9 now with these
devices
start thinking about new aspect ratios
which can go as high as 21 is 2 9 or
even beyond and on the other hand then
they can go as small as 1 is to 1 like
almost square displays so we really
encourage you to think about how your
apps are going to look like across all
of these different aspect ratios now we
understand that for some reason you may
feel that these extreme aspect ratios do
not provide the right kind of experience
for your users so we already have the
max aspect ratio attribute that you can
use to limit like you know how big it
can go we are also introducing in
Android q a min aspect ratio attribute
so this allows you to have a true
control over exactly how your apps are
going to look like across all the
different range of devices that you're
gonna see now
talking about screens we are introducing
a change which is more like a
clarification in Android q to make sure
that every display that comes out with
these foldable devices or devices in
general has a minimum width of 2 inches
now this is important because if we want
to make sure that you have enough space
to comfortably put up to 5 icons in your
navbar as well as there is sufficient
space for a keyboard input now with that
I would like to invite on stage Adrian
[Music]
thanks a lot
hi everyone I'm Adrian I'm a software
engineer on Android and I'm the lead on
foldables so let's talk a bit more about
how you can make sure that your apps
work well on these new form factors one
of the important things you can do is
ensure that your app supports app
continuity so what is that really it's
what we call the concept of being able
to seamlessly like have your app
seamlessly change between the fold at
the unfold States without losing any
state of the user so in this example
here you might have a video player if
the user is watching a video and they
fold or unfold they don't want to lose
that state like they won't still want a
look at the same video and playback
shouldn't interrupt so on a technical
level what this really comes down to is
handling configuration changes folding
and unfolding is really nothing other
than the screen size in the
configuration changing and this is
existed on Android for a while now we
have a great developer guide on our
website on developer of Android to come
and it goes into a lot of detail on what
to do and how to handle those
configuration changes but sort of the
most important things to look out for
are that you always choose the right
layout when a configuration change
happens to really take advantage of the
added screen real estate or properly fit
it if the screen size reduces when you
fold the device back closed
and another thing you really need to pay
attention to is restoring state that the
user is currently experiencing like
positions in scroll layouts or something
like the current page in a viewpager or
where the user currently is in a tab
navigation and also really make sure to
not drop any input the user has already
entered like text in a text view or
where the keyboard focus currently is
let's also talk a bit more about Android
resizable activity so this is a manifest
flag that we introduced together with
multi window support quite a while ago
and it indicates whether an activity can
run in a different configuration than
what the local screen configuration is
and when you think about it it's really
required for multi window right because
your app might not occupy the whole
screen and so it needs to experience a
smaller configuration than the whole
screen the name is a bit unfortunate
however because even if you set this to
false it doesn't mean that you never
experience the resize in your activity
because the orientation of the display
might change or now refold balls also
the effective screen size might change
and you still need to handle that so
even if you set two resizable activity
to false make sure that your test
configuration changes even with such
activities now there's one case were
previous to foldable phones we didn't
really expose your activities to Orion
or to configuration changes ever and
that was for orientation locked
activities that are also not resizable
so don't support multi window and for
those activities we are introducing a
new compatibility mode in Android Q
which ensures that your apps don't see a
configuration change instead take at
letterboxed and scale to fit the screen
and the user of course has done the
option to restart your activity in the
new and native screen size however for
the best user experience
recommend that you avoid falling into
this case and support multi-window by
setting resizable activity to fall to
true alright so speaking of multi-window
on these form factors with the increased
screen size
it's like multi-window is really getting
more important to take advantage of all
that screen space and so i'd also like
to take a bit talk a bit more about what
changes we made and how to take best
advantage of that in android q like one
of the biggest multi window changes is
the introduction of multi resume and so
to change from previous version of
androids is that previously only at most
one activity could be resumed at the
same time I was not really indicated to
user which one that is and so it got a
bit confusing if you know one activity
might react a bit differently than
another even though it looks totally the
same and it was also one more state you
have to worry about as a developer
without really gaining anything so to
simplify things starting with Android Q
we are just keeping all the top folks
focusable activities resumed so in this
example here you would yeah all all
three activities are in the original
state in this situation on Android q
however beware that you can still end up
in the pod state if there's a
transparent activity launched on top of
you or if your activity isn't actually
currently focusable such as in
picture-in-picture mode
so multi reason which should be most
licious work out of the box for you all
apps really but one important case that
needs to be handled is multi resume
together with using exclusive resources
such as the camera or the microphone so
now that more activities are received at
the same time it might happen that you
are resumed what someone else is
actually trying to access the same
resource that you are so in this case
here if you launch three camera apps
simultaneously obviously only one of
them cannot get can get the access to
the camera so make sure that even if you
are resumed you handle the own
disconnected callbacks that you might
get with the camera and also reconnect
once the camera becomes available again
also to notice that even if you disable
multi window with resizable activity
falls it does not really guarantee
exclusive access because there might be
a floating activity on top of you or
with multi display devices you might
actually even have resumed activity on a
totally different display we are adding
a new call back to activity which tells
you about the top Drizzy on state and
that really just corresponds to what
resume to be used to mean on previous
platform versions and then finally i'd
also like to talk about drag drop
quickly drag and drop is really becoming
a lot more important and powerful
now that multi window is becoming more
prevalent but that all depends on you
and your apps actually implementing that
again there's a great def guide on line
please check that out and if drag drop
makes sense for your app please add it
and with that I'd like to welcome
Michael to the stage he's gonna talk
about his experience applying all of
this
thank you dream my name is Michael I'm
the team lead for one passwords on the a
droid platform and one password is a
secure way of storing your most
sensitive data we store things like your
login credentials your banking and
credit card details and much more but it
isn't sufficient to just store that
information it needs to be accessible to
you when and where you need it in a way
that's natural and effortless am I not
coming through or can everyone hear me
now in a way that's natural and
effortless on the devices that you
you're using so this pursuit of meeting
you where you are on the platforms that
you use originally led us to pursue
developing and one password for the
Android platform and then to optimize it
for tablets then to optimize it for
Chrome OS and now for foldables and in
the process of doing so what we've done
is we've created this sequence of steps
where we've iteratively improved the
user experience for the app on each
successive platform and with each new
platform that we add we then are able to
leverage and build upon the improvements
from the previous ones when Android apps
first launched on Chrome OS we knew that
we wanted to be there because it was
where people were using apps it was you
know Chrome OS has had breakaway success
in the education market it is now a
market leader for laptops and so we
wanted to be there to where our users
are and we wanted to provide a seamless
experience that provided a responsive
layout and allowed us to take advantage
of the optimizations and the design
layout that we've done continue to use
the larger real estate available on
tablet devices so what that necessitated
for us
was to make use of resizable activity
and to allow our activity to be
recreated
so one of the challenges that we
encountered was that in the process of
allowing our activity to be recreated we
discovered that well the very first
thing that happened was it crashed and
this happened as a result of us
depending on config changes Flags in the
manifest so what would happen is we try
to resize the window and in the process
of trying to resize the window one
pastor would crash because we were
trying to manually handle configuration
changes ourselves instead of letting the
framework handle it for us what we did
to resolve that issue was to remove
those config changes flags from the
manifests refactor our code so that we
weren't dependent upon configuration
changes being handled manually and
instead we allowed the framework to do
what it was supposed to do which is
recreate the activity and then load the
appropriate resources based on the
configuration parameters that would work
to resolve the crash but unfortunately
it didn't you know expose another issue
for us and that issue was that
now one password when you would resize
the window it would lock now one
password needs to lock in order to
protect user data we don't want people
to be able to access your data when
you're not intending the you know them
to have access to it and so when you
leave the app or after a certain amount
of time one password will lock but we
certainly didn't intend for it to lock
every time you would resize the window
it turned out that this was a side
effect of some assumptions that we'd
made about the activity lifecycle that
actually didn't hold true in practice so
we had to go back and we had to
re-examine these assumptions and rectify
them in our code and once we did we were
able to deliver a an experience that was
a reflowable adaptive experience that
took advantage of the real estate
available on the device based on the
windows size available so for us one of
the big lessons and the big takeaways
was really we just need to get out of
our own way and let the framework do
what it does best in the case of
activity resizing we need to stop trying
to handle
Changez ourselves and actually that the
framework do it in the case of drag and
drop for example we just need to add a
few lines of code and you know append a
couple XML attributes and that took care
of itself so be mindful of assumptions
that you're making around things like
activity life cycles and be aware of the
tools that are there in the frameworks
and Android best practices that help you
to deliver the seamless experience that
you want to deliver and if your
experience is anything like ours when
you follow those practices the rest of
the rest of it will fall into place and
you'll wind up with an excellent user
experience across multiple form factors
and environments and with that I'd like
to welcome Ian from Gameloft to talk
about their experience bringing asphalt
9 to more than just phones thank you
hello can you hear me my name is Ian I'm
a platform lead developer at game loft
so first I'll start with a shameless
plug for those of you wondering this
game is asphalt 9 so if you haven't
already checked it out I invite you to
try it out on the on the google play
store if you guys were to ask me how it
was to develop on android a couple of
years ago I would have said the screen
is static the resolution is never gonna
change the input method its touch maybe
even multi-touch that's not gonna
there's no keyboard there's no Mouse
like all that stuff if that's for PC
memories limited network be super
careful with network conditions it's
really slow but if you were to ask me
the same question today I would say you
would have to make a game that runs on I
have no idea basically it has to run on
absolutely anything so the way we
approach this is
we try to develop for something we call
a device unknown device unknown means we
can make no assumption about the device
we're targeting device unknown has any
resolution and all resolutions at the
same time even the resolution can even
change at runtime dynamically and the
way we'll do that is our editor would
allow game designers to anchor different
UI elements the different to each other
to the screen edges and whatnot and even
allow them to resize it in real time so
they can preview what the game looks
like at different resolutions as they're
editing it and this allows them to be
creative while the engine takes care of
all of the grunt work behind the scenes
this unknown device also has different
input types as keyboard it has mouse
which is single touch like it's a single
input as opposed to multi-touch
controllers
touch like we actually don't know when
we tried to support everything and the
way we do this is we try to guess the
users intent - based on what he's where
he is in the game at the time along with
the different components that are
connected to the device so for example
if he has a controller connected and
he's in a race chances are he's gonna
want to use it to play the game we also
assume that everything is dynamic we
have no idea what hardware specs are
actually around the device we have for
example different GPUs different CPU
frequencies different amounts of memory
and the way we do that is will detect
all the specs put it all together do
some magic and figure out what events
what effects should be turned on and off
or the texture level that we should be
making in that particular game and that
allows us to have the high-end devices
at top quality while the lower end
devices will still have super good
response and a good FPS when is the same
apk basically that's running on all the
devices and the final step is that
everything is dynamic so we have no idea
what the screen size is we can't assume
that the screen size at the beginning
will be the same as at the end we have
no idea when its user will plug
something into the device at hand and of
course we're wrong and we know that
because there's no way to do all this so
will will always allow the user to go
into the game settings and go and change
his input method or whatever so
basically our takeaway here was you can
November you can no longer did develop
for one single device we have to develop
for all devices and assume that you
don't know anything because we have no
idea what new devices will appear
tomorrow and now I'll hand it off to one
day
[Applause]
Thank You Ian and hi everyone I'm Andre
I'm a software engineer with android
framework window manager team and I work
on a multi display so foldable phones
may have several screens but you can
also find multi display in cars in
phones connected to larger screens in
desktop mode in Chrome OS and so on and
the same best practices that you
implement to handle screen size changes
orientation changes or multi window will
let your app work well in all of these
use cases let's start with activities
there can be several ways how one can
end up on a different display on
foldable devices it can move between
displays when the user of folds or
unfolds the display and on all platform
versions a regular start from one chair
or from system can move I can create a
new instance of activity on the
secondary screen or it can find an
existing one on a different screen and
move it from there the actual behavior
will depend on the launch mode that you
define in Android manifest and also they
intent flags and options that the caller
sets who start the activity when moved
to a different screen should keep in
mind that the following things can
happen a context may be updated window
resized and configuration and resource
may change so let's talk about context a
bit the activity context which is the
visible entity is different from non
visual application context also
available from services and other non
visual components and the context of a
visible entity is always adjusted to the
screen area where it is shown so to get
the current display matrix size and
resources make sure to always use the
current visual context such as activity
also some system api's will get display
information from the context you provide
for example if you want to make sure
that a toast will show up on the same
screen as the current activity you will
it's probably better to use the activity
context and in general it's usually
wrong to try to get display metrics or
resources from non activity context
because for example application is non
visual entity you can get the result
that it can be completely for a totally
different screen in most cases you can
expect different screens on the device
to have different sizes densities and
resolutions and this means that the
activity will probably get a
configuration change and if it declared
you can only change the androidmanifest
it will get an education if not it will
be relaunched and in some cases it may
be even better to handle the
configuration change yourself because it
may result in a more fluid user
experience configuration also drives the
resources in your application so make
sure to update the used assets and
layouts whenever the configuration
changes and if you need to know what the
current display is after some changes
happened on create and on configuration
change are good places to check
also when activity moves between screens
there can be multiple configuration
values that change the same time here's
an example in addition to size and
density changes screen properties like
orientation layout and even support
footage will change as well any of these
even a single one can cause an activity
relaunch if you don't declare that your
activity handles it if the declared
launch mode for an activity allows
multiple tasks then start on a secondary
screen may create a new instance of
activity for example in this case the
caller requested lunch on second display
with flags new tasks and multiple tasks
and it created a new window of Chrome on
the second display it's best for you to
check what kind of experience you would
like to provide for your application and
if you want to support something like
this consider using a shared source of
data and multiple view models
and also take advantage of other
architecture components Multi resume
also applies to multi-screen scenarios
and several activities can receive user
input at the same time even if they are
from the same application so keep in
mind that activities could receive input
even in non focus State on previous
Android versions you can try that out if
you try to interact with both apps in
split-screen at the same time and they
will both respond in most cases focus in
the system usually defines where the
untargeted input whole call for example
where we'll go the key events from the
keyboard so what if you want to use
those additional screens first step is
to learn what this plays are available
in the system by checking with this play
manager this place may have different
characteristics you can check their
flags their metrics and their state to
find the one you want to use for example
you can look for a large screen to
present your media content or you can
filter out the displays that are
currently off sometimes the system may
restrict activity launches on certain
displays for example a display may be
private in this case a call to start an
activity will throw a security exception
in queue we added a new API to check if
current security restrictions will allow
the caller to successfully start an
activity on a specific display and
finally you can launch activity there by
using the activity options API added in
Android all let's speak about new
additions in here we added support for
software keyboard window on secondary
screens there is still only one software
keyboard window in the system but it can
move between screens and move to a
different display is handled in similar
ways to displays change like when
rotation happens the system will send
the display configuration change to the
keyboard process and it will update
the context and resources at runtime we
also added support for wallpapers and
android framework will create a separate
instance of wallpaper service engine for
each display so if you want your live
wallpaper to support multiple screens
merge make sure that the service of the
surface of each engine is drawn
independently and you can declare
support for multiple screens for your
wallpapers by enabling this in full
paper info XML definition another
important addition is support for
launchers on secondary screens we added
an entire new category to intent filter
to provide dedicated activity for
secondary screens instances of this
activity will be used on all displays
that have enabled system decorations one
display will have one instance of such
activity it must have a launch mode that
does not prevent multiple instances and
it is expected to adapt to different
screen sizes a user can set the launcher
of their choice on their device and if
the currently chosen launcher has a
dedicated activity for secondary screens
it will be put there by the system the
AOSP implementation now includes this
and we also put a sample multi display
launcher that showcases how to use some
of these new capabilities so the next
question is how can you test all this we
realize it's often very hard to get the
latest and greatest hard greatest
hardware so we added support for
foldable devices in Android emulator so
you can start building right away
currently there is a 7.3 and 8 inch
emulators and we'll be adding more
screen sizes and width as we see more
devices launching in the market you can
use the foldable emulator to test app
continuity to see how compatibility mode
works for apps that declare fixed
orientation or aspect
ratio and you can also check out how the
mantra resume will impact your
application to test multi-display on
real devices in hue we added a new
developer option called force desktop
mode when enabled it will turn on the
system decorations on all supported
screens and it will also show mouse
pointer there instead of the default
display combined with enabling freeform
windows also from developer options this
will create a desktop like window in
experience these and some other window
and related options usually require a
device reboot to start functioning just
so you know on pixel you can try it
using a simulated screen which you can
also find in developer options and if
you have a device which Hardware
supports HDMI or DisplayPort use over
USB C you can test it using a wired
connection as well we also released a
developer guide for foldable and
multi-screen devices today on Android
developer website we put the best
practices and in-depth information there
that we think should help you making
your app work in all these environments
so definitely check it out
[Music]
you